[Music]
thank you so much and yeah I think those
of you who clap before I think you maybe
agree with me that you hate writing
tests so yes so um yeah I hope I'm gonna
help you uh by giving you this talk
so um let's see oops oh okay so um
what do you think is the most difficult
part of writing tests um so already I
double click so I already show you my
first one which is importing the code
because uh I I'm a very messy person by
the way if you know me I my room is very
untidy and stuff so
um also I my code you know I try to be
tidy but sometimes you know I got too
many files and then they're all mumbo
jumbo so uh sometimes importing the code
is very challenging for me because the
python just can't deal with my messiness
and can't get my code into the test
Suite but anyway
um so next thing is to um organize the
test
because again I'm a very messy person so
organizing the code is already very
challenging so to organize the test is
extra challenging because
you know if you have right you need
tests if you're a good developer or data
scientist who test your code and have
write a lot of tests then it soon become
very very big and you have a lot of
tests right and because you have to test
different scenario different cases and
it's like oh my God like it's a huge you
know if you have a huge library or a
huge amount of code you would basically
double that amount by having everything
passed out right so you were pushing
with 100 Corporation right so it's like
a lot of tests and also think of the
test case because test case you know
sometimes difficult again we don't want
to write too many too many like
parameters to test our code with all
these like different what if the user
have this input what if we have this
data
um so the test or the to cover all the
grounds right like sometimes we don't
know what we should do whether like what
is the edge case maybe if what if we
have a missing data you know empty
string what happened
um
so
I don't like testing I don't like
testing but with hypothesis actually we
can uh save some trouble by the the last
it doesn't help you to import the code
if you're a very messy person like me
then you have to learn how to be less
messy but
um for the attitude actually hypothesis
may help you so what do I mean so
hopefully I'm gonna explain later but
before that I'm going to tell you about
myself I'm Chuck hello and I work for
Anaconda so uh I I mean like well we are
all day working with data so you may
heard of alaconda that we had you know a
distribution of something like python
with all the like scientific packages
but we also do a lot of different things
nowadays for example Pi script so if you
want to know more talk to me afterwards
um and I I love open source project I
have been involved in multiple um open
source in the past I contribute to some
of them uh also I organize a lot of
events that's a few of them that I have
been involved in the past
um so and I love seen people
so
um have you heard of this thing called
property based testing
oh no some some yes yes yes no yes okay
so uh poverty-based testing uh
I haven't got to explain to people right
when they are new to the concept so uh I
would say that what we normally do when
you know when you learn how to code or
when you like kind of look at the
textbook example that like oh this is
unit test so those usually are done by
tests by example
um what do I mean by that right
um because test by example like the name
suggests you have to provide example you
have to provide like what needs to be
test so for example you have a function
you want to test that you have to think
that or some input may be coming in then
it may be a number right so a number
that is one or maybe it could be zero or
it could be a negative integer or it
could be a decimal number so you have to
think of what is an example that you
would like to test and also you know
with that input also what are you
expecting to come out right so those are
all the examples
test by property is the other way kind
of is a little bit different instead of
thinking okay I need to test one I need
to test zero I need to test 2.5
I just say that it's a number uh is you
know is a number it could be decimal uh
it's not an integer but it's a number so
that that's tests by property so instead
of thinking about what the input or what
the
um so what the parameters that you put
into the test of the function uh what is
the property of that so
um oops I hope it worked okay
uh so if you type your code right so now
you know uh with these like all these
modern version of python I would say
like 3.9 3.10 3.11 we already have the
typing Library built in so uh actually
the community is now starting to get
into this practice of typing your code
you would for example you have some uh
parameters uh you would say that that
should be an integer that should be a
string and so on and so forth or what is
the output of this function so we all we
type everything right even though python
is well known for duct typing which is
very beginner friendly but as we go
along when we like really writing
production code we have to be more clean
or careful about this so we will type
our code
and but that actually it works very well
with property-based testing because we
just think of what's the property of
that variable that parameter but if you
test by example again of course we we
know when we see that okay this supposed
to be an integer then I can come up with
an integer it's fine I'm smarter than
hypothesis kind of but you know you
still have to do extra stuff for all
your tests and um
also a edge case so again like if it's
let's say you test the integer right
what are you testing right it has a very
small integer it has a very large
integer do you test zero do you test
negative is negative integer okay and
stuff so you have to think of all these
cases that for example if you test
positive integer you test one you test
something very large maybe you won't
test three four five six seven because
you know if one and you know two is fine
then maybe three is fine you don't have
to ever test every single integer you
just need to test the edge case maybe a
very large integer right
so uh but then you have to think of that
yourself
test testing the property if we choose
the right strategy if the strategy is
written correctly then the these Edge
Case Logic should already be embedded so
we don't have to worry about ourselves
every single time
and um so hypothesis uh like I said they
they provide a lot of tools that can
help you to do the property-based
testing properly so first of all uh when
you do hypothesis so the first thing you
will do is to use some decorators so for
those of you who are familiar with pi
test you know Pi tests provide lots of
decorators as well for you to help your
test to be more clean and Powerful for
example uh if you have a lot of test
cases you can use parameterize in pi
test and then you will
um you know you just need to use a
decorator so hypothesis is similar you
use a decorator to modify your test so
that it would take in an input and then
we would just say what the strategy we
use for that input
so now I mentioned strategy so we we
need a strategy right so in hypothesis
there's actually already some strategy
that's written for you uh for example
there is a the the you know the text
which is for the strings uh or numbers
you know there's a lot of things that is
already in there so you don't have to
write your own strategy you don't have
to be like okay if it's an integer it
has make sure you test zero and stuff
you don't have to because it's already
um there which is good and because
everybody use the same strategy so
something if something is wrong someone
may already make a PR or something right
so it's good we like reusing things
right we don't like inventing the wheel
every single time
um so this is an example so this is
actually if you look at the hypothesis
documentation you will see this is
basically like a one-on-one example it's
very good because
um I wish I could show you but because
technical problem I can't show you but I
will tell you what happened if you try
this out yourself but anyway this is the
example and it's a very simple code it
got only two functions one is encoding
something
so the other is
decoding something right
um so it's very simple you don't have to
look into the code and see like okay
what's going on there how do you encode
it and don't worry about that we just
use it as an example so
we have a very simple kind of code that
we want to test
so we create a test so this is using
hypothesis like you know you only so
this is the most simple case possible
you only need two things The Decorator
that we're using and the strategy so The
Decorator that we're using in this case
is called given so it's just that we say
we give the property to this variable
um and then we have to put pick the
strategy so in this case because we're
encoding some strings so we use the text
strategy so this is how it goes you just
put it there given a text so the first
so we only have one variable here so
there's no like you know kind of or
which one code first but we have the
variable s here which will be a text
okay so this is how we test it we do
this this called round trip which means
that we encode a text and then decode it
if this pair works together they should
give us back the original thing right
it's very straightforward so again you
can look at the documentation if you
want to look into the detail if you want
to try it yourself you can try it
yourself so
um so okay this is the time when I'm
showing the demo I will show you how
does it work and stuff so what happened
is that uh you you may not find out just
by dry running the code but what
happened is that if you run this test
you will have one error so the arrow
says that
uh if s is an empty string then it will
fail so oh what happened here hypothesis
found a edge case for you which is like
you when you write the the logic of the
of the functions you may be overlooking
that what if something is empty then it
will give an error but if you use
hypothesis to test because sometimes you
know we have blind spot right when we
write the uh the test ourselves we may
think of the case that we were thinking
when we were writing the code right
since we are not already thinking about
the empty string when we test it we may
forget to test the empty string but
hypothesis we find that for you so
instead of thinking okay I may test one
two three four as a string or I can test
apple or a hello world as a string then
um hypothesis we will find the the case
that is usually we call it Edge case the
case that we usually Overlook for us to
test so voila that's how it works
um
and oh thank you and
um
I haven't finished yet so uh for
hypothesis uh why am I like talking
about it like in pi data I'm telling you
this because it's not just useful for uh
you know developer or coder it's it's
very useful uh it has the um the
scientific thing in mind that um we have
a lot of things that support the the
library that we love and use a lot for
example numpy we actually have things in
hypothesis that are designed to use with
numpy for example Uh Oh but before that
before you use it right don't forget to
install the extras because hypothesis is
a very big library and for people who
may not be doing scientific programming
they don't need it right they never use
numpy so they don't need so they will
just install the core hypothesis so they
just peep install hypothesis but that's
without the numpy thing in there so if
you want to use this thing that I'm
going to tell you in these two slides
make sure you install it with the square
bracket numpy there
um yeah I think if you were using a uh
Zs
shelf in uh Mac like if you're a Mac
User like me then you may have to put a
code there because uh the square bracket
they don't like it the shell doesn't
like it so you have to work around but
it's fine you'll find a work around
um so after you have installed then you
have this so this will be in your
hypothesis it's sitting in extra
so uh it's you know it's just in numpy
so you can import stuff from there you
can import
strategy that is designed for numpy for
example the the scalar you know you know
High scalers you use it a lot and you
know a raise you know the what what
numpy is like powerful for is because
they have all these like vectors and
arrays that you can do this calculation
very quickly so you may want to import
that type for example if you're
expecting a numpy array in your function
you can use hypothesis to test your
numpy array which is great
um
so yeah if you want to again look into
the documentation if you want to know
the detail also it supports Panda stuff
so wow how do I do that again install
the numpy is is it kind of together so
it's install numpy it's not install
pandas but it's fine you know because
pandas use numpy under the hood anyway
um so it sits inside the extra dependent
so it's there and then from there you
can import the strategy for the numpy
index the numpy series and the num sorry
numpy pandas in the expander series and
pandas data frame so
we use a lot of data frames and what if
we can have a strategy to test the data
frame we don't have to you know for
example you're testing some kind of data
pipeline cleaning data or something so
instead of you know have to make up with
some kind of testing sample of your data
frame you can use hypothesis which is
good I'm lazy I don't have the right
test yay
um yeah so
talk about lazy I am so lazy that I
don't even want to write tests right so
remember the first example we have is
actually quite easy to use hypothesis is
that writing many many tests with many
many cases and think of the cases as
well you can just hypothesis think of
the test case for me but I'm so lazy
that I don't even want to write any code
for the test so
I I hate myself but uh but hypothesis
doesn't have people still love me I
probably still want to help me so
um
we have Ghost Writer I don't have to
write it myself yay
um but uh if you if you are very good
like and remember there's a a kind of a
small small things here at this slide
it's like I hope you're still using
typing because if you're not using
typing The Ghostwriter doesn't know what
you're trying to do so it doesn't help a
lot so and the Ghost Writer is very
smart that goes right here it will write
tests for you and uh so what it does it
reduce typing as a hint so remember
nowadays maybe it's a good practice or
your team requires you to type every
single thing
um so now it's it's great because now
you don't have to write a test you just
spend time in writing the typing you
don't have to write the test so
uh that goes right it's very very smart
if you see the typing it would find the
right strategy for your parameter for
example again integer I will find number
string you'll find the text uh so for
all those like standard um strategy even
for example if you type it as a pandas
data frame then if you have installed
extra because white writer will know
that okay I'm now finding the strategy
for the pandas data frame yay that's
really good
um so it's a CRI tool so you just type
it in your command line interface and
then it will just generate all the text
you can pipe it into another file and
that's your test you don't have to even
write single thing you write single come
on that's it
um so also if you for example like like
me right I'm lazy but I'm messy so I
love black which is a formatting tool
which will make my clothes very tidy for
me and uh goes right to know that as
well so if when you use hypothesis and
generate the test nobody knows that it's
not written by you because you're also
using the black to format it so it stays
the same style which is good
and
um yeah that's that's really really good
so this is how you you generate the test
for example you have written well well I
think that you are not re it's not
written by you because gcip is the
standard library right but imagine we we
write okay we write this gcip Library so
it's a standard Library they've got lots
of function in it so if you ask me you
know how to write a test for gcip I'll
be scratching my head and it's like no I
don't want to do it but if you use
hypothesis hypothesis will happily do
that for you
um again I can't show you now because
like my computer doesn't like the
projector but you can try it if you have
a laptop here now if you have high
purposes you can try it and it will
generate a lot of tests for you and um
it's good
so
okay so uh why the ghost writer is so
smart uh what what do girls write to do
because you know I can't trust a
stranger to write tests I can't just
goes right to the Thai test to write
tests so I want to know what they are
doing so here's what they're doing so
first of all one thing one of The
Ghostwriter that do is to write a fuss
which is
just test your function to see if it
works right yes this is the most simple
thing we want to just run the function
run it through so there's no bug in it
and it kind of worked properly
sometimes you know you have a function
maybe raise an error so you can also
write the exception there as well so if
you know it will you know it will be
working fine until you have this
exception that you have written that you
know if someone be naughty and put
something in there then you have this
error that you're expecting then you can
put it there
um
so in deployment I always don't know how
to pronounce this word it's so difficult
to pronounce it but the concept is very
simple
um so it for example sometimes you have
a function and then running it once
should already get the task done and
running it two times three times four
times it doesn't help so for example
sorting is one thing that's like that so
after you've sort it if you have done it
properly the order should not change
right so uh you can run this and then so
Ghostwriter will generate tests for this
um so again like uh you so this one I
think you have to tell ghosts right at
that oh this is a function that you do
this but sometimes goes right is very
smart you don't have to tell ghosts
writer that I'm using this because this
is a function that should be uh you know
if you haven't changed
um
round trip is my favorite one because
Ghostwriter will know that you have a
care function it's amazing
um so to try this you can try it
yourself again you type hypothesis right
uh Json so Json is the standard library
that have a lot of things that you can
work with Json uh for example Json Doms
and Json low so they are pair again you
know it's like encoding and decoding one
of them is changing your dictionary into
a Json screen the other is doing it the
other way around so they are paired and
they should be you know
round trip should go back to where it
was right so you encode it and you
decode it come back to where it was
um so hypothesis will know so you you
can of course first of all you can of
course tell hypothesis that this is a
pair use round trip to generate some
tests for me but if you for example test
the jsons with the whole suit then you
know when it goes right to go through
the function they would use the first to
test the function but when they see wait
a second Json Dums and Json lows I think
they are pair I would use one round trip
to test them
so this is how smart goes right how it
is and um yeah really love it
so
um
yep so uh I think this is the yeah this
is the last thing that I want to bring
into your attention is the equivalent so
equivalent is useful when you are
Reinventing another function so what it
does is that it will take a function as
a it's the truth right it's the correct
answer and then test it against the one
that you are testing
so for example this is just an example I
think it won't work because well it will
work in some way that like my my
function is not perfect that's what I
mean so because if you think oh if what
if Y is negative yeah then it won't work
um so
um so yeah so what it does is that I I
take the math.pal so that's the power
method right so if you have been paying
attention in the keynote today you know
that you know in math there's a lot of
amazing things they have been you know
optimized they've been like you know
tested and they are I would take them as
the truth right so okay and then now I
write a you know x to the power of Y
function I want to test it against it so
this is how I do it so um and then I'm
sure hypothesis will tell me that oh
your thing is it kind of sucks because
what if Y is negative then it won't work
so
yeah
so there's actually two more but those
are less you know uh appear less it will
be less used uh that's why I put it here
in one slide so for example binary
operation so sometimes you know we write
some custom binary operations so it's
like the plus minus equal equal all this
stuff they're binary operators because
you have you know you have two things
you know two two things that's binary
and there's operator
um so you want to if you have custom
made one and you test them then that
would be helpful for you
um the other thing is you found you know
numpy ever knows if you found and then
you know um yeah it would detect this
okay numpy and you found I would test
something for you so it goes right to do
that as well if if it help us right
there to do it
um yeah so I can't try it now so because
the demo doesn't work so uh
I think yeah this is this is close close
to the end of my talk and I want to uh
you know because I always kind of
balance my opinion out I don't want to
be like kind of brainwashing and say
like you must use Ghostwriter and
hypothesis and they are great
um I want you to also consider these
things before you really deploy
hypothesis to all your code right oh
yeah be careful don't trust me 100
so one thing that uh for example I've
talked with uh the maintainer of cyclone
and then we're talking about oh like
hypothesis actually is quite useful have
you uh you know use hypothesis to run
the test for a psychic learn
um they said that oh yeah we have tried
but actually it can be very slow because
you know Cyclone is a massive Library it
got lots of things in it if each one of
those parameters you have to generate a
lot of test case and test everything
it will become very very slow and it's
you know um yeah so
maybe so I think I think what they do is
now is like they only pick a few things
that is like really useful to use
hypothesis I only use hypothesis on
those but not the whole thing so um yeah
so it's something you may have to also
consider if you have a lot of code a
very complicated pipeline maybe only
pick a few like a section of your code
that actually hypothesis will help you
the most and then only use it there
um the next thing is that tests can be a
little bit hard to understand because
you know until you run the code you
don't know what the test case are that
hypothesis use you can of course check
the source code and found like what
strategy are you using and like you know
what did like what the strategy generate
and stuff
um but it takes extra steps so if you
really care about what example you put
in your your test then
uh well you can work around by not using
given but use example but that's more or
less the same as test by example so um
yeah there's a benefit but also some
drawbacks
um
the last thing again like I think
hypothesis especially The Ghostwriter
work the best if you have very good
typing in your code so if you don't have
typing in your code I won't recommend
you to use The Ghostwriter because
um
you well it was to help it was to
generate the skeleton of the test for
you but you have to go inside and change
all these like strategy you have to pick
it yourself that like what strategy you
use so uh you can still try but again
like you're not getting the most benefit
if you are not using typing so
um be aware of that you can't just be
like okay I'll use Ghostwriter January
and then just run the test if you
haven't typed your code then you have to
go to check everything before you run
the test
so I think that's it for my presentation
and thank you so much and
oh do anytime
oh by the way I'll go back to the front
because there's a link to the slide so I
don't you you don't have to ask me for
the slice but any questions do I have
time for questions or not but this is
the slice
yeah
yes there's a very confident
sorry uh do will people pass the mic or
do I have to repeat
machine learning model does it work on
machine learning model is that your
question
so for machine learning model I think if
you have a pipeline right you can you
can kind of pass your pipeline to see if
like for example this section if you're
cleaning the data and all the stuff but
if you're testing whether the model is
doing its job then I think it's out of
the scope of five offices
because you know you have to you know
see the uh or the you know your your
test set you have to have a test set and
test it and compare the score and use
different metrics and stuff the
hypothesis is not that smart
how much can you control the inputs for
the test so uh all the all those are
generated by the strategy so there are
strategy that is already built in for
the library then um you know if you want
to know you can of course check the
source code or you can write your own
strategy if you want absolute control or
if you just kind of uh you
again like if it's a thing that you
really care about what cases that is
used then you should maybe go back to
test by example
yeah
yes there's oh we found the mic yes hi
um do you have any uh plans or
Integrations with uh tools like Great
Expectations that allow you to write
assertions about data distributions and
types
you know Great Expectations or why logs
or other kind of data testing tools is
so why can you shot it a little bit like
why do you use the certain cases or so
great expectations for example is a tool
where you can declare properties that
your data sets should have and then you
can run it either in line with your
pipeline or in a testing mode
uh that doesn't look in uh it looks more
like the output rather than it doesn't
generate inputs for that triggers the
expectation so is another tool that you
talk about right yes so what's the name
of it Great Expectations great
expectation okay I have to check it out
so I don't know so yeah I will check
that out yes
you still don't know what actually is
another website
yeah you can I think uh so I haven't
touched the pen this one for a while so
I I really don't know but I think you
can uh declare that what kind of type
that is inside the data frame I think
for yeah for numpy I think I work with
that one before I have a PR for that
like that you can yeah uh so yeah you
can kind of declare what with the type
inside is so yeah
yeah yes
and hypothesis together yes that's a
very good question that's what I
normally do is to use hypothesis with
python so actually the example here uh
that if I can show you again an example
or okay it's quicker it's like this okay
uh the example actually is using pi test
this one if you look at it this is
actually uh using pi test
um
for hypothesis there's also I think
there's a parameter that you can also
change it to have us uh use it with uni
test as well so it would use both but I
think most of the time in my experience
I use it with pi test
so yeah so it works
[Applause]
[Music]